hey youtubers is Charlie so I've been
getting a lot of questions about
spider-man and this isn't meant to be an
easter-egg video but there are a few
things about MCU Spidey that you need to
know going into the film primarily Uncle
Ben the Golden Age origin story in a
couple really cool details the Kevin
Feige has revealed and interviews
recently about things that aren't
directly addressed in the film but are
actually really badass so this is not
meant to be my spoiler Easter egg video
I'll be posting that later tonight
there's a new round of the Spider Man
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so you noticed that one of
the biggest missing things from all of
spider-man stories as they've been
telling so far is that there's no Uncle
Ben Uncle Ben isn't even mentioned in
the movie so a lot of people are like
wait a minute
we know he exists in the universe
because there's Aunt May Peter went to
live with him after his parents died we
all know his origin story so there are a
lot of changes that they make to
spider-man's backstory as they bring him
into the MCU just a dovetail with all
the big events that have happened so far
in the biggest is the Battle of New York
because it informs a lot of big plot
points in the movie which I'll talk
about during my full easter egg video
but the director and Kevin Feige had
some really funny reactions when people
ask them specific questions about what's
going on with MCU Uncle Ben Kevin Feige
was really coy and dodged questions the
director John Watts pretended like he
didn't know what was going on with Uncle
Ben as if they didn't discuss it which
is misdirection because yeah of course
they're going to talk about Uncle Ben
and spider-man's backstory before they
make the movie you've all heard stories
about how they wanted to make this film
feel as different as possible from
previous spider-man films without
completely throwing away all the things
about spider-man that make him
spider-man
one of the biggest hallmarks of every
spider-man film so far is that they
always do that
Uncle Ben's scene you have this extended
sequence where Peter realizes what he
was talking about when he said with
great power comes great responsibility
he witnessed his Uncle Ben die and
that's his big call to action
with great power comes great
responsibility
carjacker he's been shot but we just
called the paramedics
they're on their way back Ben Uncle Ben
[Music]
Uncle Ben
but it sounds like what's happening with
MCU Uncle Ben is that they just want to
leave that for later on they might do a
flashback in a future movie
one of the biggest theories now is that
they're changing that part of the story
Uncle Ben was not killed by the robber
that Peter let get away like you've seen
in previous films what you saw in the
comics instead they're using the Battle
of New York just like they used for
other big plot points in the movie and
Uncle Ben died during that that became
Peters big call to action that changes
his timeline just a little bit because
Peter had already gotten the spider bite
and then saw Uncle Ben die in as a
Captain America Civil War he'd only been
spider-man for about six months or so so
when this movie rolls around you can
assume that it's been about a year and a
half so that still doesn't quite line up
with the original battle of New York
because in the Marvel Universe that was
several years ago so they're just a
number of moments that are coming up in
the movies in the sequels that they
could use Uncle Ben for for big reveals
if you remember back during the Sam
Raimi trilogy they actually changed his
origin story so that the Sandman was the
one that originally killed Uncle Ben now
that isn't the way that it happened in
the comics it was a big change it was
somewhat controversial but again the
movies changing some details about
spider-man's backstory just to dovetail
him with MCU events in the one that's
most relevant to him is the Battle of
New York like we even saw him during
Iron Man 2 like he is now the little kid
that was there at the stark Expo so he
would have been there for all the big
craziness that happened during the
original Avengers movie the other reason
why I think that they don't address
Uncle Ben during the movie is just to
avoid getting super depressing like you
look at the Andrew Garfield version and
it got super gratuitous like that is an
extended scene and everybody already
understands how that works so the
current version of Spidey has already
watched him die we've already been
through that experience so we can all
see ur eyes about how the time gem in
the craziness of infinity war is going
to give Peter the idea that maybe he
could bring Uncle Ben back with the
infinity gems but that's all speculation
and they already said that they will not
tell Tom Holland who he's fighting
during infinity war mostly because he's
so bad at keeping secrets he's a little
kid so he already admitted that they
won't even let him read the script like
they're just going to feed him lines
when they need him during his infinity
war scenes which makes that they're just
super high security you probably already
seen the set pics of dr. strange
fighting one of Venice's black order in
the comics it was evany mob but we don't
know if he's going to be in the movie
but there is a small chance that they're
not telling him who he's fighting just
because he's actually going to share
scenes with fan OHS himself the other
best Easter eggs from the movie and I
don't consider these spoilers because
they're things that are never directly
addressed they're just kind of put out
there is one his suit AI he actually has
an AI that you've heard in the trailers
I'll explain that in a second but the
others are more Avengers related the
sued AI that you've heard in trailers is
actually the voice of Friday finally
here we go
sitting here cold you have 500 and only
pick possible combination the voice that
you hear in the trailers is Kerry Condon
the voice of Friday Iron Man's AI so
people thought okay makes sense that
Spider Man would just clone his AI
system and put it into Peters suit as
part of the training wheels protocol but
come to the actual movie and it turns
out that the person who voices the AI is
a very familiar it turns out that it's
Jennifer Connelly one of the reasons why
the director picked her because she has
a really amazing voice but in real life
she is married to Paul Bettany so it's
just meant to be a funny wink at that
that Peters AI is the wife of iron man's
original AI obviously Paul Bettany his
vision now so there's no real actual
link to the vision character and
Jennifer Connelly played Betty Ross and
Angley version of hope
[Music]
[Applause]
there's really no reference to that but
it's just a nice meta Easter egg so you
have Betty Ross who is also the wife of
Jarvis talking to spider-man in his head
but it doesn't really go any further
than that and he calls her suit lady for
a while until he renames her Karen and
there's no special significance to the
Karen name either
the only real Karen in the Marvel
Universe is Karen Paige and I know a lot
of people always wondering about
daredevil crossover defenders crossover
the director has made some comments
about trying to do blade or possibly
Morbius in the future movie but that's
just speculation I don't actually think
that they're going to pop up in the next
spider-man film probably the other
coolest Easter eggs are Captain
America's new shield meaning that Iron
Man and he will eventually reconcile
before infinity war it makes sense that
Iron Man would want to bring him back on
the team if he's putting everybody back
together to prepare for Thanos in this
crazy vision that he's had in there's a
bell from Thor that shows up during the
movie people think that it's a new belt
but it's really just one that he left
behind it's a very very interesting
theory
not a simpler one you're all not worthy
so it's an old Bell from Thor left over
from age of Ultron when they were all
still living in the stark tower so I'll
explain more about the Easter eggs what
happens it sets at the next movie
there's just a lot of spoilery things
that I can't talk about till I post my
spoilery video there is some more Game
of Thrones that I'll post later tonight
but I will drop my post-credit scene
video later tonight so you guys will
have a chance to see it make sure you
stay to the end of the movie they set up
some really big stuff it's going to be
really exciting to talk about the future
of spider-man in the Marvel Universe
he's critical for their phase 4 but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner chill Mike please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details you can
click here to rewatch that prequel
sequence and you can click here for
brand new philosophies and for
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight